Philip how are you today hey dad doing
well thank you
I'm doing okay since I picked you guys
to go to the Super Bowl I got a little
nervous first week against Kansas City
you know granted is win against Buffalo
it'd mean a whole lot more for my
prediction if you can beat the Rams can
you take care of that it's a lot it's a
long seed it's a long seed and Dan so
your prediction prediction still got a
chance for us for a long way regardless
of what happened week 1 or this week but
ya know it's a it's an exciting week
playing rams kind of what's now become
across Colorado I guess and so uh
they're a heck of a team obviously the
shutout yesterday had a big win against
Oakland in the opener so behind of a
chance but it was big to get our first
win yesterday it's Buffalo it will have
a good week preparation ready to go
did you know Vontae Davis retired at
halftime I did not know why after the
game I did not know I did not know what
happened I noticed it wasn't out there
anymore but I didn't know no that was
the case because I don't know as a
quarterback are you aware of who's
playing the positions certainly a
cornerback you know from play to play
are you keeping an eye on who who is in
and who's not
well I mean not not maybe not so much
play to play but yeah then that sudden
all said you know it is hey thirties in
a corner and you know 20 playing the
nickel you know they're nickel Gaines
went out early in the first quarter with
an injury so you kind of yeah you know
you know who's where sometimes it's it's
it's because of things you want to run
on certain guys and other times it's
just so you can identify who's who at
who's playing what but yeah I did not
know that tool until till postgame a
locker there's definitely definitely a
lot of chatter about it the locker room
well this a guy who's been around ten
years and then all of a sudden he says
I'm gonna I call it quitting I don't
think that's retiring you you can't wait
and play a second half against against
you guys I'd be surprised at that yeah I
certainly don't want to make light of it
or in any way anyway try to test this
character in his reasoning it was so
adversity he's been in this league a
long time but that was certainly a
first for me on the light side of it I
did get a few texts from my buddy saying
that not only young lady got retired the
first half you know so the guys that did
make light of it but no I know I'm sure
sister probably put out a fixity put out
a big statement so yeah it's not
something that he feels convicted about
what did you tell John Shaolin after the
game you know I was able to meet Josh
last year spend kind of a whole day with
him and kind of the classroom and and
they were out here and in Orange County
and at the same agency I mean I don't
know we don't have a great friendship or
anything but I didn't know I'm a little
bit prior to so I really just told her
hey Josh you this your first start of a
long career and you're gonna get better
every game it just stay with it you know
I mean there's there's gonna be some ups
and ups and downs at the quarterback
position there still is and I'm 200
games ahead and many of all of us are
there always will be but I think that I
think he's got the right approach and
he's destined for the game he certainly
has the certainly has the physical
talent he's Phillip Rivers Chargers
quarterback got the Rams coming up next
Sunday at the Rams what was your first
start like what do you remember from
that we played in Oakland it was my
third year so I've been there I've been
there two years withdrew it's look Doug
Flutie was part of that to her back
group I work here
so my first start was in Oakland on the
second game of a doubleheader all those
on that Monday night and oh so much like
Oakland started with last week and we
threw the ball 11 times I was 8 for 11
for a hundred yards and a touchdown San
Antonio Gates and he still laughed that
that day because I threw a touchdown and
I was all excited is my first start
we're winning 27 nothing and I remember
grabbing him saying I have to be the
first of many and you know like we're
gonna throw it 11 times now that we got
you playing literally we know though
there was there's gonna be 80 something
for between 80 and I so certainly
remember that first award yeah big hit
from orange snap I mean that was a it
was a miracle night for sure your
throwing motion I'm curious if that
would be changed now if you were coming
out of college would they try to alter
that
I don't know I mean maybe I mean I
remember my first year at NC State dorm
joga tired and he asked he has he had
suppose injured and he sent it he sent
the tape to Mike Holmgren and over and
said hey if he's accurate get that up
quick and I wouldn't fool with it so he
didn't and then I remember as it got
close I think I just thankfully had four
years of college football that so even
when I got the NFL it wasn't we tweaked
some things you know I used to drop the
ball down a lot lower just from release
you know just before I even threw it so
we cleaned up some things my first
couple years in the league but as far as
the actual throwing motion they've left
it alone and once I run it was crazy Dan
is my oldest son Bao is 10 and he throws
it exactly the same way I mean exactly
and I remember he's about seven or eight
I was like hey Conor you can pick that
ball up a little bit higher now he's
like well that's how you do it I guess
we're gonna roll it
how far can gunner throw it at ten he
can throw pretty good now I I'm biased
I'm biased but he's uh he is very much
exactly how I was that age but even
further advanced from a football
standpoint I mean we didn't have flight
football growing up you know and I did
play tackle toss a seventh-grader but
this flying football now is unbelievable
what it can do for a young quarterback
or skill player as far as understanding
windows and reading this guy is throwing
a curl flat I mean ten years old I know
what a girl flat was and uh and so he's
uh he's all into that it's a lot of fun
I enjoyed you know to coach him and do
some of that the spring I have one other
son two six he's just now getting into
it so it's been a lot of fun kind of
seeing him get involved in the fly
football do then Alabama recruit you
Alabama did not I was a they didn't take
a quarterback that year I don't know if
you remember the name Tyler watts
Andrews out they were split in time his
redshirt freshman and then Brody Crowell
was just a couple years behind me he'd
already committed to Bama but I didn't
take one that year and Auburn had
already had to commit
from Jason Campbell which that worked
out great they went undefeated with
Jason Campbell that one year one year I
can't remember what year was but he was
there and they did offer me they'll
offer did but they they hinted that I
was going to be a tight end dan can you
imagine a place I did I would have I
would have been coaching high school
football about 15 years ago you could
have taught gage something about playing
the position tough and scrappy but I
would have four years oh my god so
here's a you know Hall of Fame
quarterback and somebody wanted to make
you into a tight end here's what's funny
there's no Mazzoni was the coordinator
there Tommy Tuberville and we have a
little place down in Florida now and
it's right next to Tommy Tuberville
place and so he and I always laugh about
that and then no Mazzoni who was the
coordinator there ended up being the
coordinator at NC State my secret and I
was his quarterback my senior year so
it's kind of funny how gonna still all
connected even going back to those those
recruiting days we were trying to bet on
how many kids you have now I went with
eight my guys were here all day I got
you got eight you nailed it
are you done held it six six girls and
two boys no well I should talk to your
wife does your wife know that you want
to have more oh yeah we're six girls
she's yeah six girls I tell you what the
three oldest are girls and and now
they're 16 13 and 12 so we have a lot of
Mike and a lot of little mamas in the
house helping out doing but it's awesome
do they think you're stupid though no
well sometimes you know like that yeah
but it's it's awesome there's a lot of
always a lot of action at the house as
you can imagine but it's curious any
boys come over again I'm sorry any boys
come over yet with your 16 year old
daughter
no no not not yet not yet no no no
everything's good so far right
if the funny thing is I married my wife
I mean we are married when I was 19 and
my wife was 18 so it's a little bit kind
of going just there our life Tiffany
Tift can you imagine like at least two
years you were married and we had Hallie
it's crazy
so yeah but no no I think I don't see
that I don't see her going the exact
same path as far as age yes she shows up
in a hurry you know I'm hoping not you
know what I'm doing I would have Bosa I
would hire bozo to just stand there
shirtless and when boy comes over to
take her to a dance just you know you
got the message out early to you know so
the boys yeah so they'll pass it on here
yeah yeah they would definitely be more
intimidating than me answer the door I
just said boast boast and Ingram answer
the door together make it being good
state and I like that your longest
career run can you do you know how how
long it is I don't know I want to say
yeah I want to say well I had one call
back I had like a 14 yard touchdown run
called back against Buffalo actually
years ago 2012 maybe 11 or 12
pulling a 15 yard run Oh Paulie what's
the longest run by film I got a couple
15 yard runs in an 18 yard Oh
18 yard run I was back I was fast
how many quarterbacks do you think you
hate in a 40
could you get ready minute that big III
think Brady and Eli it would be that
there would be some pulling and tackling
of us competitive it would be a it would
be a fighting and scrapping for a five
flat one of us would ads out the other
but it would it would come with any and
without any pulling and scrapping it
cheatin for sure well I hope you can
outrun Aaron Donald this weekend yeah I
can't outrun him or sue but I don't like
and we'll get it out before they get
back there and it's a heck of a heck of
a defense now those two throw both
corners and those in
and I don't want to slight the rest of
that defense you go you go shut out a
team and NFL it it's you know you got
you got a heck of a defense and
obviously McVeigh and that offense it's
hot powered as well so it'll be a heck
of a challenge but we'll be there will
be there will be there at one o'clock on
Sunday that's for sure
all right just remember Phil when you
win I win when you lose I lose so just
so you know Thank You bud appreciate
your time Phillip that's Phillip Rivers
Oh a lot of fun there all right I don't
know if his wife knows that he's got
eight I'm gonna guess that they probably
just got maybe they just want to get
eleven eleven on offense here or eleven
on defense yeah see that's crazy though
about how you know he got married at 19
and 18 and his daughter 16 man that's a
mind-blower yeah four more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
act
[Music]